[Music]
looking for an educational experience
for the entire family how about mining
simulated mining JC Fernandez heads to
Henderson to show us more in this week's
Vegas drives
[Music]
good welcome to the mine experience here
at macaw School of mine thanks for
having us man super excited to be here
I've always heard great things about the
place first time here just looking at it
it looks spectacular
[Music]
foreign
Hall truck tire these uh mine hauler
trucks as you can see there they are
some big trucks this truck holds six of
these tires the tires are 12 feet tall
whoa and every tire is about forty
thousand dollars per tire tell me about
the uh the little train you had right
here well this train right here is an
actual underground train you can see by
its low profile it can go right down
that tunnel there and this was given to
us by the Nevada National Security Site
so this has all the different kind of of
train cars that you'd have in a in an
underground train the Personnel car for
people to ride in the explosives car
cars to carry in different machines and
this is actually this was used at one
point yes yes there at the Nevada Test
Site big green thing over here tell me
about it we call that our big green
monster that is a rotary blast hole
drill that is used for going out and
exploring and trying to determine
whether there is stuff below the ground
that they want to build a mine around so
they'll use that they'll drills down
into the ground and get a Core sample
and test that core sample and see if
that's uh you know got something that
they want there's so many different neat
little nuggets here on the other
property it's so cool we got a visitor
center here yes this is our visitor
center right here let's go check it out
what do we have on the wall here this is
a map of Nevada of course and we use
this to show where all the mines are in
Nevada all the gold mines okay we have
in Nevada if you want to see where we
have the Silver Mines those are all
those different Silver Mines okay now
watching gold and silver they seem to be
the same amount of Lights yes because
every time that you find gold you're
going to find silver as well so they're
all Gold and Silver Mines so JC this is
our simulated underground gold mine is
it actual size of a mine it is this
really is our Jewel that's detailed in
every way to look like an actual gold
mine there's little nooks and crannies
here this cart was actually used in a
real mine yeah all the things that we
have we've had donated to us by mining
companies and all these rooms here we
use to teach kids and the public about
the mining industry
this is our our careers and Mining room
we talk particularly about women in
mining because there's a lot of great
jobs in the mining industry a lot of
people aren't aware of so originally
back in the old days they would use a
canary like this down in the mines and
see if there was bad air because if the
canary dies you know everyone's in
trouble then right they'd have to get
out now today they have electronic
devices they still call them canaries
and paint them yellow but this is what
they use to check for air better for
canaries and better for humans that's
right so this is a simulation of a
blasting wall you drill the holes you
push your Dynamite into the hole
dynamite and grab the plunger plunger
where you'll fire in the hole fire the
hole run
so JC this is our last stop here in our
elevator room all right got an actual
elevator here yeah come on jump in was
this used in a mine yeah
oh it uh it moves it shakes Bill if
people are watching they want to
experience more what do you guys have
coming up we're hoping to get more
information just go to our website
theminexperience.org for all the details
all right I'm ready to go down send me
down send me down
[Music]
the mine experience is open for tours
this Saturday and their annual Gala is
taking place September 24th Mercedes